No. 24 You entered the country, and then you
automatically qualify for battle
.
I've heard that this country is surrounded by greenery and is rich in the blessings of forests.
And the people who live there are wonderful people who live modestly and simply.
It's a paradise of collar clouds hahahahahahahahahahaha
And that's what the battle is about In
this country once every three months there's a triumphant contest for citizenship for three days The
upper part is a match for mother blood  Citizenship will be granted to those who rank first.In
addition, medals will be awarded directly from the university, and one new rule can be added to this
country.Cure Freedom Only surrender if the other party approves.Refuse to
escape from the liner and reed-type firefighting.  Burger, I'm a slave for the rest of my life But this is the rule of this country I
see, I have one question
.  If you let them enter the country without saying anything, everyone
will look
like
a fool.  I was saved by doing that,
but my husband was killed next time. That was a masterpiece
.
Boy, you have a weapon, don't you think?